tasting dream team here from BuzzFeed
calm the website what are we gonna do
today Emma we're gonna go and drink some
jelly Benedict to Jen's one of them it's
gonna be 0% alcohol so a non-alcoholic
tin and either one it's going to be the
strongest gym in the world and the
carton relieves that percentage but it's
over 70% alcohol okay let's get drunk
yeah we have a product called sea lip
which is an alcohol free spirit
technically speaking it's not a genus
there's no juniper and it doesn't
contain any alcohol but the ritual of
using it and mixing it is exactly the
same as you would do a gym they
currently have two flavors this is sea
lip spice which is their original and
then this is the second one which is
their garden one away which has got hey
pops and sweet pea and they take the
various different botanicals like you
would find in a gym and just still run
individually and then those distillation
are blended together I'm gonna do a gin
tonic with the seed lip spice and then
with the garden and do cocktails on our
list at the moment called a walk in the
park
I'm a fan of gin and tonic but I'm not
really that much of a fan of alcohol so
I feel like this is my dream that's
really not so it doesn't taste boozy I
like that
he wouldn't put this in front of me and
I'd be like oh yes what is Alicia's gin
and tonic I'd be like yes this this will
satisfy me instead of a gentleman I
would just think mrs. your mantle my god
we know the difference honestly I like
it this really fresh oh it's it's really
nice yeah it tastes like really fancy
juice would proudly order it and people
wouldn't take me for not drinking
sophisticated young woman miss Kay's a
young woman about town while we're doing
this we are going
[Music]
at the Oliver conquest where they do
over 400 different gins and one of these
gins is the strongest gin in the world
which is seven to six percent alcohol
we're gonna get really drunk
do they have three gins they have a
regular there for the Navy which is 57%
Linda of the uncut normally when you
distill you will take the spirit from
the steel which is about seven e 80% and
you'll cut it with water back down
sporty back to a regular strengthening
what strain the Sun there's not cut it
with any water
the reason they let out the uncut is
because the distiller thirsty tasted it
straight from the still and saw that the
flavors were so amazing that you just
wanted people to taste it
how he taste it are you feeling brave
enough to try
[Music]
when we serve 76% I thought we'd both be
like bent over spluttering and we're not
gonna mess around with some cocktails
and a signature serve with a gin tonic
the signature serve isn't the groaning
just because the flavors are so intense
that it can stand up with the strong
flavors in a Negroni that is lovely
yeah that's so nice right
I thought you'd have to pick me up off
the floor on the way out but I mean we
may still have you don't admit this
could be like absolutely lethal where
it's one of those drinks where you're
like oh yes so delicious and then after
one you're just gone they just taste
both really nice and really strong in
their flavors it tastes more citrusy and
more flavorful
if that makes sense
I don't know I've just had 76% Jenny
making any sense
[Music]
I like that yeah again when it's like
when it's mixed into the cocktail it
doesn't taste any stronger the I can't
handle alcohol and usually I feel like
76% let me knock me out but because I
feel like I could actually drink all
night which is probably quite dangerous
[Music]
weirdly not a huge difference I think
people on the Internet are gonna hate me
for saying that but seed lip is such a
good alternative if you don't want to
drink wheat for whatever reason I think
the biggest surprise was the 76% oh yeah
there are some Navy strength genes that
I've had the taste stronger than this
one and they're about 20% weaker which i
think is crazy I'm sold
this is great tanta look we need to get
the drink yeah we do have to go back to
work after this
[Music]